ladies and gentlemen of the class of 17
use flat screens if I could offer you
only one tip for the future flat screens
would be it the benefits of flat screens
have been proved in Hollywood whereas
the rest of my advice has no basis more
reliable than my own meandering
experience I will dispense this advice
now enjoy the confidence and optimism of
Greenfield projects
oh never mind you'll not appreciate the
confidence and optimism of Greenfield
till things start going wrong but trust
me when you finally ship you'll look
back at the code you wrote and recall in
a way you can't grasp now how simple
everything seemed and how productive you
really were your code is not as bad as
you imagined don't worry about changing
database providers or worry but know
that every company who used an ORM in
case they needed to switch databases
never actually did it the real problems
in your projects are the dependencies
you can't control the engineer who
unexpectedly leaves your team at 4:00
p.m. on some idle Tuesday learn one
thing every day that scares you
optimize don't reformat other people's
code bases don't put up with people to
reformat yours rebase don't get obsessed
with frameworks sometimes they help
sometimes they hurt it's the user
experience that matters and the user
doesn't care how you created it remember
the retweets you receive forget the
flame bait if you succeed in doing this
tell me how keep your old hard drives
throw away your old network cards
refactor don't feel guilty if you don't
understand f-sharp some of the most
productive junior developers I've worked
with didn't know F sharp some of the
best systems architects I know still
don't write plenty of tests be kind to
your keys you'll miss them when they're
gone maybe you have a degree maybe you
don't maybe you have an open source
project maybe you don't maybe you wrote
code that flew on the space shuttle
maybe you worked on Microsoft SharePoint
whatever you do keep improving and don't
worry where your next gigs coming from
there's a big world out there and
they're always gonna need good
developers look after your brain don't
burnout never be scared to take a break
it is the most powerful computer you
will ever own launch even if you have no
users put your own q8 I have a plan even
if you choose not to follow it do not
read the comments on YouTube they will
only make you feel angry
[Music]
cash your package dependencies you never
know when they will be gone for good
read your log files they're your best
source of information and the first
place you'll notice something starting
to go wrong understand that languages
come and go and it's the underlying
patterns that really matter
work hard to fill the gaps in your
knowledge because the wiser you get the
more you'll regret the things you didn't
know when you were young codon 86
assembler once but stop before it makes
you smug code in Visual Basic once but
stop before it makes you stupid
read accept certain inalienable truths
your code has bugs you will miss your
deadlines and YouTube might end up in
management and when you do you'll
fantasize that back when you were a
developer code was bug free deadlines
were met and developers tune their
database indexes tune your database
indexes don't deploy your code without
testing it maybe you have a QA team
maybe you have integration tests you
never know when either one might miss
something don't best too much with your
user interface or by the time you ship
it will look like a karaoke booth
be grateful for open source but be
careful whose coach run sharing code is
noble but there's more to it than taking
bits of your projects folder putting a
readme file on them and hoping if you
upload it to github someone else will
come along to fix all your problems but
trust me on the flat screens
[Music]
good afternoon Sydney are you all having
an enlightening and educational
conference are you enjoying yourselves
are you coming to pub conf good alright
the author Douglas Adams once came up
with a set of rules that describe the
way human beings react to the technology
around them in the world he said
anything that is in the world when
you're born is normal it's just a
natural part of the way the world works
anything invented between when you're 15
and 35 is new and revolutionary and you
can probably get a career in it anything
invented after you're 35 is against the
natural order of things
now this is me I was born in 1978 just
too late to see Star Wars the first time
around the World Wide Web
I was born into a world where ARPANET
already existed where computers already
existed where we had color TV and you
know the idea of computer networks and
things but the Internet as we sort of
recognize it now didn't really exist yet
things invented the web was kind of
invented when I was around 15 years old
and I did go on to have quite a good
career in it I started as a webmaster I
learned HTML I did you know all these
kinds of things the things that were
invented after I turned 35 and are
therefore unnatural and against the
order of things are the Apple watch
fidget spinners and something called
dabbing which I still don't know what
that is but you know the point that
Douglas Adams is making there is that
our experience of technology is
incredibly subjective so much of it has
to do with at what point do we first
encounter these devices and sis
terms and ideas that go on to change the
world around us you know and it's easy
to forget that the things that are all
around us every day these amazing pieces
of kit that we all take for granted that
just work you know another thing Douglas
Adams he said technology is stuff that
doesn't work yet when it works it's just
stuff you know like chairs don't fail
anymore because we don't think of this
so we don't think of chairs as being
technology um but you know the point
he's making all these kinds of things
that we take for granted every day all
of them started out as hacks and
prototypes and ideas and you know things
that were held together with string and
glue and code and gaffer tape and
technical debt and eventually they
mature and you know if your first
experience here is the column on the
left you probably still think of all
these things as a pretty controversial
idea and if your first experience is the
things on the right well yeah of course
we live in a world with smartphones and
electric cars why would we not you know
imagine that and it's easy to think that
there is some sort of Darwinian survival
of the fittest that we have all these
prototypes and all these ideas and all
these solutions to problems like smart
phones and digital communication and and
the best solution is going to win but
that is absolutely not true
and what I'm going to talk about today
one of the ideas behind this talk I want
to look at the points in the history of
the web where something just kind of
happened for a dumb reason and I'm gonna
tell you a story about what might have
happened if it had gone ever so slightly
differently so let's go back to the
beginning in the beginning IBM created
the mainframe and it was good a computer
so powerful that Thomas J Watson who the
the Watson AI system is now named after
thought the world might one day need as
many as five of these computers during
the second half of the 20th century
scientists and engineers took all of
this computing and information theory we
aren't from valves to transistors to
integrated circuits we went from
in code to assembler to interpreted in
compiled languages you know these
computers made their way out of
laboratories and you know companies and
universities and started making their
way into people's homes and towards the
end of the 1970s IBM dominated computing
in a way that you know you can't quite
you think of the biggest companies in
the world today you know Google and or
alphabet and Apple and Amazon all of
them you can probably think of someone
so you know Apple are dominant but other
people are still selling laptops other
people are still selling smartphones IBM
basically owned the world in the late
1970s when it came to information
technology and they realized that there
might be an opportunity here to sell
people a computer that you could fit in
a car and take home and actually have in
your house you know turns out Tom Watson
was wrong maybe they could sell more
than five and there was an opportunity
here now IBM in the 70s was a juggernaut
you couldn't steer it it was this
massive enterprise that was incapable of
doing anything quickly because it would
take six weeks just to approve the font
for the purchase orders and so they came
up with an interesting idea they put
together a team to create the first
personal computer the PC they were
frightened of getting left behind and
they made a radical decision they said
we're not going to manufacture this
thing we I B M are gonna buy parts off
the shelf that are being made in
factories all over the world
we'll pick stuff up where we can we need
a motherboard get one of those processor
Intel have those serial bus yeah get
some of those out of Taiwan or China or
Singapore or wherever the stuff is being
manufactured and they needed an
operating system and so they went
shopping they went to see the best
software company in the world when it
came to building operating systems for
home personal computers and who was that
in 1981 we'll find out a little later
now then while IBM are working out how
to put computers in your house the
Advanced Research Projects Agency ARPA
is coming up with this crazy idea to
connect computers together and you know
they had this good idea like if we could
connect four computers together so that
if one of them
wiped out by some kind of Cold War
military attack the other still worked
that might be a good idea let's start
engineering here for resilience and
around the same time as IBM was
launching the PC ARPA published a
specification for an intern networking
protocol the standard which became known
as ipv4 was published around 1981 this
is actually a map of a map of the
internet from 1973 of every single
device that was correct connected to the
ARPANET before it became the internet
drawn by hand by a draft person with a
pen and paper that's every single device
and what they're running you know this
was published in 1981 January 1st 1983
became known as Flag Day that was the
day they said from now on everything
connected to our network must run tcp/ip
that's it
1982 they ratified a standard called
SMTP the Simple Mail Transfer Protocol
we suddenly had this system where all
the computers in the world could talk to
each other and a system where the people
using those computers could send mail to
one another now the internet started to
grow and the problem with systems that
are growing is you need a way of keeping
track of them now there are only two
really hard problems in computer science
one of them is cache invalidation the
other one is naming things so let's talk
about DNS because before DNS was
invented if you set up a new server and
you put it on the Internet you would
plug it in and then you would phone Jake
and you would say Jake I got a new
computer can you add it to the hosts
file please this was the hosts file it
was a file that lived at the network
information center at Stanford and when
you know one of your team was going
there for a meeting you'd say how can
you grab a copy of the hosts file and
bring it back oh you'd FTP it overnight
when the phone calls were cheap or you
know you'd get them to send you a copy
on a tape or something but this was how
organizations managed their list of
hosts that were connected to the
internet with this one file if you
wanted to add a machine to the hosts
file on a public holiday you couldn't
because the people who had permission to
edit the file we're all off celebrating
with the
you couldn't add machines at night or on
the weekend or at Thanksgiving or at
Christmas and it kind of worked for a
while but it was obvious that this
internet thing was likely to start
growing a little bit and maybe we needed
a better system so enter this guy ass
poor maka Petrus from the University of
Southern California which also invented
UNIX and LSD so thank you
University of SoCal for those
contributions to society and they hired
him and they said look we need a better
thing better solution to this host
system we got these five different
engineering solutions could you look at
them all and you know just just pick the
best ones and keep everyone happy now I
quite like what he did next cuz I think
it's what I would have done next he
looked at all five of these solutions
went these are all crap and threw them
away and he designed and invented by
himself
DNS a hierarchical database of host
names and Network addresses which has
the fantastic quality you know it has
survived pretty much unchanged from his
original specification because he
designed it to scale with the complexity
of the network it was supporting the
more hosts you connect the more DNS
servers you've got the more you can
share the load the more stuff gets
cached the fewer root level lookups
actually have to happen to make that
system work and you know that still
survives today supporting hundreds of
millions of domains now so the scene is
set tcp/ip exists DNS exists smtp exists
we've got conventions and protocols
computer hardware you know commodity
hardware is cheap lots of people have it
and in cern on the border of France and
Switzerland this guy Tim berners-lee web
developer is he actually he uses this
job title that that's the real title
that Tim berners-lee uses and I love
Scott Hanselman Slyke he could have been
the web developer but he's like no web
developers fine and he's working at CERN
and you know he's noticed they have
these fantastic computer networks now
but most of his colleagues who are
physicists and mathematicians if they
want to publish their work so someone
else can read it they don't really have
kind of digital equivalent of journals
and he thinks you know what if we could
come up with a way of publishing
material on online on the network so he
writes up a proposal information
management Tim berners-lee and he sends
it to his supervisor who sends it back
with a three word comment vague but
exciting now it is really easy in
hindsight to think well obviously that's
the world wide web that's how it was
gonna end up you know this idea of HTML
and HTTP and links and all this kind of
stuff um I was studying at the
University of Southampton in 1997 and
one of my professors actually two of my
professors there had worked on a
competing submission for hypermedia
before the world wide web was invented
there was this big international hyper
media conference and one of my
professors he said I was sat there and I
got up and I showed them my system and
then the next guy who got up was this
chap called Tim who had come over from
CERN and I sat there and I thought yeah
we're not gonna get this one um but the
system that the the Southampton team had
was a thing called microcosm and this is
actually a screenshot of a running
microcosm system on running on Windows
3.1 and microcosm didn't use embedded
hyper media because their philosophy is
we don't want people to have to edit
their documents because these documents
already exist we don't have to rewrite
everything what we'll do is we'll invent
a network server that can maintain a
database of links independently of the
material that's being linked so you can
put your you know your text files and
your rich text files and your
WordPerfect files and whatever on a
network file share and we will run a
indexing service over the top of them
that doesn't touch the original
documents but it looks for keywords and
contexts and it links things into other
things and it shows you all of the links
here in a separate window running
alongside your content so that you're
always presenting the original document
the way the author intended it to be
done and the hypermedia is being applied
by you know librarians and information
analysts and you know it's fascinating
just to see this now has survived
microcosm became multi cousin PLC who
now do a very good line doing discovery
and you know big lawsuits where they've
got all these documents and files on
some companies subpoenaed serve
and they use a variation of that tech to
this day to go through an index all that
material um but you know this is a
completely different philosophy on how
online hypermedia
might have worked but you won't lock
this door with the key of imagination
beyond it is another dimension a
dimension of sound a dimension of sight
a dimension of mind
you're moving into a land of both shadow
and substance of things and ideas you
just crossed over into the twilight zone
[Music]
[Applause]
we're at Sun it's the early 1990s Tim
berners-lee is in his office he's been
playing around with something called the
mesh and a couple of other people have
also got projects that are related to
mesh systems and things and he's
thinking he needs a new name for it and
he has this idea he thinks what if I
call it the World Wide Web and he's
scribbling www on pieces of paper and
ideas and everything and then something
fortuitous happens one day the network
goes down and he has to tell someone
what he's doing
over the phone and he picks the phone up
because when he goes yeah it's this this
www and they say hang on a second
that acronym is actually longer than the
thing it's short for this is gonna if
this catches on it it might sound a
little bit daft and Tim thinks you know
that's a good point so he calls his
colleagues in when they're all having
tea at four o'clock in the afternoon and
says look I got this thing and I need
some names for it what do you think and
someone is yeah well World Wide Web
yeah I see the problem with that one
what if we call it the International
information interchange the ìiî and so
Leo's name sounds like pirates and
someone who's just read Neuromancer says
what about the multinational metadata
matrix and they think oh yeah that
sounds like it could have potential
they'd play around with these ideas for
a little while eventually he comes up
with the global repository of
interlinked documents the grid he's got
a name
he needs a protocol protocols are always
called to something something something
Transfer Protocol File Transfer Protocol
Mail Transfer Protocol
he's like I'm slinging hypertext here
hypertext Transfer Protocol and he looks
around things well there's a couple of
basic operations for you know publishing
and updating documents and he looks at
structured query language SQL and he
thinks you know we can borrow some ideas
from that we'll have a verb in our thing
select means select that document from
that server bring it back to me create I
want to publish something on the grid
update I made a mistake please take that
document and update it with these
changes
delete means take that down the lawyers
have just got in touch and that's not
supposed to be there and someone walks
into his office goes you know maybe it's
just possible it might end up supporting
more than that what if we add submit as
well so you can send instructions to a
remote system get it
something for you now one of the things
that Tim really likes about these is
they're all the same length so when you
view your your weblog files or your grid
log files in a fixed-width font
it'll lines up nicely wouldn't it sound
like a nice engineering solution the
next thing they need we've got a
protocol we've got a name we've got all
these these resources these grid pages
that are going to be out there on the
internet somewhere we need a way of
identifying the ones with with looking
at the thing we want to select he plays
around for a little while he comes up
with something that becomes the standard
unique resource finder the word serf
looks like it might catch on you know
people might talk about surfing the grid
that could be interesting and he comes
up with a draft for this and the first
draft of it is HTTP colon slash slash
user app pass that grid domain.com colon
port slash path question mark query hash
fragment and someone goes why are you
putting username and password
credentials in plain text on something
that's going to be part of the user
interface and he says good point we
shouldn't support that that would be
stupid
HTTP colon slash slash grid domain comm
port path query fragment and he's
thinking you know we could probably make
this a little bit simpler lets you know
query and fragment and normally going to
be optional so we'll just we'll delegate
those to stuff that's just being used
for search and indexing and stuff and
then he comes up with will will have
default documents so we can just go grid
domain comm and that'll host a default
document and then he thinks what is the
slash slash thing that is that you know
II got it from UNIX file systems but
this isn't a file system this is a
completely new thing let's get rid of it
and then someone points out that if you
put hosts on your network whose name is
a number that could be ambiguous between
the host name and the port number this
is a problem they think what could we do
about this he changes it he goes with
HTTP bang grid domain.com exclamation
mark that separates the protocol from
the resource from that from the host and
then he has a good idea at least what if
we just establish a convention that if
there is a host on your network which
has the same host name as the protocol
you're using we can leave that part out
completely grid bang domain.com that's
it
that is the fully qualified grid
of the default document on your server
bang nailed it and one of his team
serves to hit Tim don't you think grid
bang CERN dog sounds a bit silly and he
says not a silly HTTP colon slash slash
www.tsiyon.org and they says yeah yeah
right good point it's good thing we
fixed that one hey next up we need a way
of presenting these documents a way of
presenting this hypermedia and he starts
out with a proposal he's looking at a
thing called a standard generalized
markup language which has existed since
the early 1980s in industrial
typesetting that kind of thing and he
thinks we could use a simplified version
there so he comes up with this HTML
naught point one draft he sends around
some of his colleagues now Tim works at
CERN soon as a physics laboratory most
of his colleagues are scientists
mathematicians physicists they publish
equations which have lots of less than
this and greater than that and they come
back and they're like please don't use
angle brackets like literally every
document we've got will break the second
we try and publish it on your grid
system because we use those angle
brackets for something else and he
thinks that's an interesting point so he
takes a corpus of all the text files
that are already available on ftp
servers and you know online on various
network shares and he does a frequency
analysis to find the least common ASCII
character in all the publications at
certain anyone want to hazard a guess at
what it might be it's the tilled it's
Eskie code d7 is the least frequently
used character in the basic ASCII set he
thinks right that's it the tilled will
be the the mark up signifier character
in my new language plays around with it
okay first rule let's take a double line
break that's a paragraph break that
means the vast majority of text files
are already valid grid documents because
people have been writing in plain text
they don't use tools very often and
they've been using return return to
indicate a paragraph right let's just
preserve that behavior so a lot of these
documents we can publish online without
having to edit them at all it comes up
with some ideas around markup there we
go that's a heading that's a paragraph
it's got some bold text in it comes up
with something a little more elaborate
eventually he circulates his
after HTML version not 0.2 he's got this
: key value syntax for denoting
attributes so this is an HTML HTML
document the language is English he
realizes that most of these things are
gonna have some metadata which is for
machines to read and present elsewhere
in the user interface and it's gonna
have a document part which is for people
to read which gets presented in the main
user interface there are headings those
paragraphs he invents a way of linking
which he uses linked for because it
creates links and someone says Tim what
do we call it anchor and he's like what
is anchor why would you call it that
that makes no sense he creates a way of
embedding images he publishes this
specification online at about February
of 1992 and the world goes crazy
everybody gets grid fever suddenly
companies all over the world of thinking
we need to get some of that we need do
we know anyone who can do that historian
people start taking like a 2-day course
and setting themselves up as grid
masters and running very very successful
businesses because they know how to
print a business card and they know that
no one else knows that they don't know
what they're doing because this is also
new and exciting which incidentally is
how I got my first job but it finally
peaks with the launch of the first
graphical open source grid browser thing
called NCSA mosaic from the National
Center for supercomputing applications
based at the University of Illinois this
supports all of the existing Network
things that supports nntp so you can
read Usenet with it it supports gopher
supports FTP but it also supports this
new grid protocol it can browse grid
pages it can display images it can link
to other things and the world stands up
and takes notice now you remember I said
at the beginning that in the early 1980s
IBM had this this personal computer and
they were shopping for an operating
system to run on it so they went to the
best in the business you know the
absolute finest group of engineers who
are working on personal computer
operating systems anywhere digital
research and gary kildall the head of
digital research had a knock at the door
one day it's IBM going we want to buy
your operating system they sit down they
have a bit of a chat
now what gary kildall has real
and IBM haven't is that if your flagship
computer is made out of off-the-shelf
parts that you bought from China and
Singapore and Taiwan you don't actually
own anything the key to running
applications is no longer the hardware
because anybody can buy that the key to
running applications is going to be the
operating system and so kildall thinks
for a minute and he goes alright I will
sell you a license to use my CPM a
control program for microcomputers a
license that's why BM you can copy and
ship as many copies of these as you want
and I'll give you a 50% discount if I
can have a license to do the same thing
myself and I can keep selling it the
deal is done
IBM ship the personal computer with CPM
86 gary kildall and digital research
continue to develop it when IBM launched
their first 16-bit computer the pc 80
and 1984 digital research already they
got a thing called MPM 86 it's the multi
multitasking program for micro computers
it's a game changer it's the first truly
multitasking operating system doesn't
have any legacy constraints there's no
640 K memory limit imposed by the 808 6
processors it is a protected mode 16-bit
operating system runs on 286 processor
and pushes the thing to the limit but
what really kicks them into the big
league is that it runs on any compatible
hardware there's companies all over the
world now popping up with these beige
clones of IBM boxes buy one of those put
a digital research operating system on
it by the time IBM realized their
mistake it is too late Digital research
is rapidly becoming the biggest company
in the world
now ad in California there's competition
there's Apple who have had a pretty good
run since the Apple 2 computer was put
together in the late 70s they've done
the lessor they've done the first
Macintosh everything is not healthy at
Apple headquarters there's a lot of
strife there's a lot of conflict and
eventually in 1987 there's a hostile
takeover the shareholders take Steve
Jobs the visionary genius who founded
Apple Computer and they kick him out on
his ass and he moves across the street
because he wants to rub in their faces
what he's gonna do next
and he starts a new company next they're
done with page everything they've known
is gonna be black they come up with a
thing called the next station
it is a black cube about eight inches on
a side nobody's really ever seen
anything like it yeah
the next these IBM clones are going for
eight nine hundred bucks the next
station retails for ten thousand dollars
it is aimed at cinema production it's
aimed at medical research it's aimed at
really really high power software
development a couple of these boxes end
up in Sun Tim berners-lee is using one
of these to develop his prototype Grid
applications the first grid browser
which being next is called grid browser
application actually was built and run
on on one of these next systems
meanwhile Digital research merge with
the second largest software company in
the world
the wordperfect corporation the United
States Department of Justice flaps
around for about 18 months going
something must be done we can't have a
company that powerful won't somebody
think of the children but they can
actually come up with a way to block it
and so perfect digital is born they're
planning something big they have the
best office suite in the world they have
the best word processor in the world
they have the world's leading flagship
operating system they're thinking you
know we need a a grid browser we need a
way of browsing the grid from from our
platform so they go and they have a chat
with these guys anyone recognize these
two blues blue shirted individuals so
the chap on the left is Jim Clark Jim
Clark was the founder of Silicon
Graphics spent the 1980s building these
incredibly high-powered 3d graphics
workstations the chap on the right is
Mark Anderson Mark Anderson has been
working at NCSA here's one of the
founders of mosaic he's one of the
engineers who worked on the original
mosaic grid browser and they have both
for various reasons they've both quit
their jobs and they're fishing around
for something to do next and our
thinking here maybe we could we could
start a browser might be a good idea we
could build something you know mosaic
was all right let's kill it let's build
a mosaic killer we can call it Mozilla
how about that for a name
but then they get a phone call the
Nintendo corporation ring amount and say
look we got this new you know a Nintendo
64 console we're working on and we think
it would be really neat if you could
plug this into the phone jack on the
wall and you could play like Mario Kart
and and Donkey Kong against your friends
around the world
and Jim Clark and Mark Anderson they
think long and hard about this and
eventually I think you know this
actually sounds like a pretty good idea
the Mozilla project never happens they
moved to Seattle they start working for
Nintendo and who do they meet walking
around the office in their first week
there but these two illustrious
gentlemen the two John's John Carmack
and John Romero couple years previously
over the course of a very very long
weekend fueled by a lot of pizza and
caffeine the John's Carmack and Romero
had ported Super Mario Brothers 3 to MPN
eight-six and they put it on a disc and
they sent a copy to Nintendo and they
said check this ad we managed to get
side-scrolling out of a 286 CPU they
said nobody could do that and Nintendo
went this is brilliant come and work for
us and they did off in Seattle Jim Clark
Silicon Graphics Mark Anderson from
mosaic John Carmack probably the finest
graphics programmer of any generation
John Romero who's quite good at level
design and having good hair the four of
them sequestered away with Nintendo
bankrolling the whole project who knows
what they're going to come up with in
the meantime the team at perfect digital
are back to the drawing board they have
the gem three desktop they're 286 visual
operating system they have a whole bunch
of things they need a grid browser so
they go to the next name on their list
they are knocking and they discover that
the law school at Cornell University
some guy called Thomas Bruce he's a
librarian he runs the library and he has
written an grid browser for NPM and gem
systems now the perfect digital
corporation has fantastic relationships
with the legal community because
WordPerfect is the de-facto word
processor for every legal firm in the
United States so they very rapidly
hammer out a deal they acquire the cello
source code they rebranded
they optimize a couple of the libraries
they add a couple features they come up
with grid perfect they got WordPerfect
they got letter perfect they've got no
perfect bank grid perfect there it is
their grid browser and they include
something which goes on to change the
face of distributed computing they
extend it as well as the grid global
repository of Internet insolent
documents protocol they come up with
something called safe secure application
frame encryption for the first time your
Grid client can talk to a grid server
and no one else can sniffing on what
you're doing no one can see Audion
suddenly the submit verb that they put
in the original protocol takes off
because people can do all kinds of
things with it it's not just get me a
document update that document delete
that document they've included word
perfect in their grid browser so anybody
who can read the grid can write the grid
they have publishing capability baked in
from day one so anybody who acquires a
copy of this thing they have full-blown
WYSIWYG authoring tools going along with
it but it isn't long before people start
thinking having to do everything in
terms of static documents here is
proving really really restrictive do you
think there's some way could we find
like a programming language we could
embed in the grid client and on our grid
servers so we could actually start
delivering rich applications and
behavior on this thing now in the
mid-1990s if you are going to embed a
programming language in a piece of
business software there is only one
choice there is an obvious contender for
this and that contender is lisp half a
century old that still has a perfect
timeless era bennett a few coders from
each new generation rediscovering the
lisp arts
your father's parentheses elegant
weapons for a more civilized age paul
graham is running a startup company
called via web and what via web have
realized quite early on is that lisp is
a fantastically good language for
building grid servers the grid protocols
are stateless and Lisp natively supports
a concept called continuation passing
it's a way of capturing execution
halfway through some chain of processes
capturing its nap shopping it and then
resuming it at a later date in a way
that you don't need to constantly be
allocating state and shared memory and
all kinds of overheads and resources and
things Lisp is the obvious choice now
around this time Sun Microsystems
who have been happily turning out
Solaris boxes they've invented a
language as well they come up with a
thing called Java which is a run
everywhere blah blah blah
object-oriented whatever and they're
pushing this thing hard they want
everyone to be using Java for everything
there ever is and they come knockin they
go and see perfect digital and they say
hey you know we'd love you guys to get
on board with this Java thing we're
doing and perfect digital light actually
we've got this language already and they
say well maybe you could rename it what
are you calling at the moment and they
say oh gotta call it hyper Lisp
could you call it Java Lisp or love a
script or something java re' so they
call Paul Graham in for a meeting and
over the course of a long afternoon he
explains his philosophy on programming
language design he tells them about the
history of Lisp he tells them about
symbol types he goes through something
that he would later publish online it's
called the blub paradox about how all
programming languages are not created
equal
by the end of the afternoon Java is
basically dead hyper Lisp has won out
the thing that clinches it is when he
points out that every piece of java
hyper Lisp every piece of hyper liske
program code is also an expression and
every expression is also a data
structure the language is completely
mutable you will never need to serialize
or deserialize anything because you can
literally take a program that is half
executed turn it into a data structure
pipe it over the wire to a client that
will basically rehydrate it and just
keep running it where it left off it
gives you this fantastically powerful
expressive model for running distributed
client-server applications he turns to
the finances and the bean counters he
says look this basically means everyone
who starts using your application is
effectively donating their computer to
you so you can run code on that so you
don't need to invest in so much
infrastructure
it's like DNS it scales with the number
of people who are trying to use your
solution that is it Java is out the
future of client-server Grid programming
belongs to hyper Lisp and I'll see what
it looks like
sure you do so we have HTML which by
this point is on 4.0 1 because 4.0 had
spelling mistakes in the specification
you can embed blocks of hyper Lisp code
directly into your code the simplest
possible thing you can do is you can say
alright we're going to now this reads
backwards because it uses a prefix
notation so we're going to bind and
we're going to bind the load event of
the document I'm not going to say
document object because this is Lisp and
it's cleverer than that we are going to
bind the load event of the document to a
lambda this is a callback and we're
gonna say when it happens pass the
element that triggered it and the event
that happened and run some code and that
code is just gonna say alert hello world
a a hello world in hyper Lisp let's look
at a slightly more sophisticated example
now so now we have a form on our page
and we're going to bind the submit event
for that to a lambda now reading it from
the back we've got this grid submit
method that you can see in here and what
that's going to do is it's gonna use the
network code baked into it and send a
callback back to the server and get some
response back from that and when it
receives the response from that because
this whole thing is completely
asynchronous by design because why would
it not be it will set the value of the
span to whatever came back from the
server and then down here we got a
little bit of kind of boilerplate markup
syntax and so this is a distributed
client server what in a parallel
universe they take 10 years to invent
and they'd call it Ajax and it would be
horrible this comes out of the box this
is free because we have symbol types in
list we can map the elements and the the
sort of fundamental runtime of the
browser directly onto symbols so they
don't need name spacing or qualification
we can have hyphens in our variable
names because all of our arithmetic
operators use postfix notation so this
convention around styling which is
growing up about spaces versus camelcase
underscores hyphens is the thing that
everybody settles on that just works the
lambda callbacks built-in give us a
synchronous client-server communication
out-of-the-box it is a beautifully
simple powerful programming model we're
just beginning to explore the potential
of it when there is trumpets and fanfare
and perfect digital announce gem 95
their most powerful desktop operating
system ever they get the Beatles back
together for the launch party they're
using the grid browser is baked into
this operating system from the ground up
they're shipping a free version of
WordPerfect with no printer support that
will let you write an author documents
and put them on the grid they have this
massive party The Beatles do get back
because they're using this back button
from the browser in all of their
marketing literature and everybody loves
it the future is bright the future is
fantastic unless you are working for
Apple who have kicked Steve Jobs out and
are now kind of wishing maybe they
hadn't because things have gone from bad
to really bad to worse to really worse
and they are floundering around trying
to work out what they can do they need a
new approach they need a new operating
system they need a new brand they
basically need to overhaul everything
that they are doing and Gil Amelio who
is the CEO of Apple at the time he goes
into a board meeting one day and he says
you know maybe we could try and buy next
and get Steve Jobs to come back they
laugh him out of the room this is the
dumbest idea and there is no way Steve
Jobs is ever going back to Apple after
the way they kicked him across the
street but he's not the only visionary
engineer who's left Apple during their
tenure there there's a start-up be
incorporated be have a thing called the
B Oz it is a completely brand new
ground-up high performance operating
system it has dedicated threading
support for playing streaming media
doing real-time communication audio
processing all these kinds of things and
what Bea have realized is their
operating system is fantastic but the
boxes the physical computers they were
building to run it on those are proving
really difficult to pin down so they
have pivoted they've changed their
strategy they are going to try
and find hardware and their first step
because both of the engineers behind it
have an apple background is to port B us
onto Apple hardware they set up a
meeting they go and see the Apple people
and they say we've got this brilliant
high performance multi-threaded you know
real mode or a protected mode operating
system would you be interested in you
know acquiring it an Apple think this is
brilliant this is exactly the thing that
they've been looking for they jump all
in they love the styling they love the
branding they love it so much that the
next line of Apple computers that come
out which are instantly dubbed banana
boxes by the press these things are
brilliant up till now computers have
been grey and beige something that they
can make them in yellow no one had ever
thought of doing this before you know
imagine a computer that wasn't beige
people want this in their house it's
beautiful it's running this amazing new
BIOS operating system the one thing they
don't have is a grip browser so they
make a couple of phone calls and they
ring the cello people and they're like
we already did the deal with perfect
digital you missed that one and they
ring and CSA and NCSA say welcome a
Lakes kind of open source and limping
along that's not really doing very much
and then out of the blue they phoned the
Norwegian telephone company Telenor and
Telenor say you know this is funny we
have a grid browser we've been working
on here it's a thing we call opera and
we're not quite sure what to do with it
so the be us people and the Apple people
and the Norwegian telephone company make
a deal and they acquire opera the source
code for that the presto rendering
engine the network stack that runs it
they renamed it be link to go with B
boxes and be us and of course it
instantly gets renamed to blink by it
autocorrect it supports all the grid
protocols create update delete select
submit it's got a WYSIWYG editor
suddenly you know there is a first-class
competitor again to the the juggernaut
which is perfect digital running on
these beige office clones now people all
over the world have got these systems
and they are writing and posting grid
pages left right and centre everyone is
getting dial-up and everyone is getting
five megabytes of grid space free when
they do this because you can publish a
lot of stuff in in five megabytes
because we never
invented those massive JavaScript
frameworks in this universe and it's
becoming very very difficult to find the
good stuff because people are just
putting crap online because they think
if they get users maybe later they can
work out how to make money out of all of
that traffic and the big unsolved
problem in grid computing has become how
do we find content how do we search for
the things that we want to look at now
at Stanford there's a couple of PhD
students Sergey Paige and Larry Brin and
they're working out of a garage on an
algorithm they called backrub and they
call it back rub because it uses links
back to documents to decide how credible
they are if lots of pages on the grid
are linking to you then clearly you're
important and then if you link to
somebody that link means they're
probably important as well it's really
really clever and you know they're
bouncing this idea around and thinking
this could could really go somewhere
what are we gonna call it and Sergey
says you know my kid was in school the
other day and and they were telling him
about this this number called a Google
which is the biggest like number it's
like 10 followed by a million zeros or
something maybe we should call our new
search engine that because back rub
sounds a little bit questionable and
remember we haven't been invented yet so
no one's gonna be able to find us so
they call it Google and they ask someone
to go and register the domain and of
course what happens is autocorrect
happens and they end up with google.com
now it's a great idea you know the
technology works works really well they
have this wonderfully minimalist
homepage
everyone else is plastering as much
advertising as they can onto their grid
portals goggle has this really nice
stripped-down page but there is just one
problem they have no idea how they are
ever going to make any money out of
something that works well is minimalist
and they are providing for free and so
they start kind of looking around for a
business plan and someone suggests maybe
you could run advertising they didn't
like that idea at all and then Larry
Page takes a call it's Steve Jobs he's
working on something something big
something secret he might be interested
in acquiring goggles PageRank technology
now we don't know exactly
Lee what took place next we don't know
what was discussed in those meetings we
don't know who paid who for what or how
much but we know what happened after
that
computer journalists April 1999 everyone
is talking about the millennium bug
we're all going to get killed on the
stroke of midnight by all these nuclear
missiles that can't handle four-digit
dates or or whatever there is a break
from the millennium bug hysteria when
all of the computer journalists in
Silicon Valley get into work one day and
on their desk they find a hand-delivered
black envelope they open it up and
inside there is a card black printed
card on the front it just says get ready
for the next generation on the back
Menlo Park amphitheater 4th of May 1999
they immediately think this must be a
Star Wars thing may the 4th be with you
so someone phones Lucasfilm Lucasfilm
say don't be ridiculous why would anyone
make a sequel to Star Wars just we are
not gonna mess with perfection and the
rumor mill starts working overtime you
know what is it why are we going what is
this next generation what are we talking
about on the day may the fourth comes
around the Menlo Park amphitheater is
the auditorium is packed a little before
9:00 a.m. hush falls over the audience
Steve Jobs takes the stage and he talks
for a while he talks about the grid he
talks about digital publishing about
empowering people about technology about
the social impact of all of the
technology and just as everyone wonders
where he's going with this he reaches
behind his podium and he pulls out his
it is that a laptop it's called the next
book nobody has ever seen anything quite
like it it's less than an inch thick
it's machined from a single piece of
aluminium
it's anodized lustrous black it's got a
no floppy disk drive
it's got no cd-rom drive it's got no
serial port how do you plug your printer
in and they're going you don't need
printers this is the future you know um
it's got two USB ports and a headphone
jack the questions start buzzing through
the crowd how do you how do you connect
that to anything how do I get my games
how do I run SimCity it doesn't have a
floppy disk drive and that's when he
unveils his masterstroke because
throughout the audience there are plants
about two dozen Apple employees reach
under their seats and they pull out
their next books they open the lid
and they are already playing the live
video stream of jobs on stage doing his
presentation
nobody has seen Wi-Fi before nobody has
seen streaming video before nobody's
seen a laptop like this before they
forget they're supposed to be
journalists people are elbowing each
other in the face and clambering over
seats trying to get a a look at this
thing they are so blown away that they
completely forget they're supposed to be
there writing about this thing because
nobody has ever seen anything like it
it's the fastest lightest laptop the
world has ever seen
333 megahertz arm RISC processer 64
megabytes of RAM five gigs a flash drive
space it's got the next version of the
next-step operating system built into it
it has built-in wireless internet it
ships with a box called the next end or
a thing about the size of a hardback
book you plug this in your phone Jack
it's got a cd-rom drive in it it
supplies the wireless networking for
your house so you don't need to sit next
to a phone jack every time you're doing
anything and of course next step ships
with its own brand-new grid browser we
say brand-new it's called Nexus and the
DNA of Nexus goes all the way back to
the very first grid browser dot
application developed by Tim berners-lee
on the next operating system a decade
earlier it's responsive it's got the
fastest hyper Lisp interpreter anyone's
ever seen it's wired right into the
fabric of the new operating system and
the whole thing is seamlessly integrated
with goggle search technology you can
bring up a window you can search for
what you're looking for it doesn't
matter if it's in your folders in your
backups in your mail if it's on the grid
somewhere it will find it for you Steve
Jobs is back with a bang the next
generation has arrived the millennium
bug comes and goes the missiles do not
go off nobody dies but we all wake up
with one hell of a hangover and the next
generation of computing looks like this
we have Steve Jobs the next corporation
the next book running Nexus based on Tim
berners-lee's operating system we've got
the banana boxes running blink the
browser they got out of the Norwegian
telephone company Telenor we've got Gen
95 and perfect digital going all the way
back to cello invented by a librarian
working in a law school
and we've got sun microsystems who for
some reason are still hanging around
going we can run NCSA mosaic look it
supports Java which nobody cares but
they've invested heavily in their
marketing and they're gonna keep
plugging away at it a couple of years
later the buzz starts Nintendo are
coming up with something big now
nobody's heard very much from them since
John Carmack and Romero and Jim Clark
and Mark Anderson all went off to
Seattle with Nintendo bankrolling
whatever they wanted to come up with and
they did ship a very successful Super
Mario quake world but after that
everything goes a bit quiet December
2002 just in time for Christmas Nintendo
unveiled a platformer that they think is
gonna change the world and it's just
called reality it is a massively
multiplayer online world an immersive 3d
experience takes the world by storm it's
John Carmack and John Romero's dream of
implementing the Metaverse visualized by
Neal Stephenson in his books or the
matrix from William Gibson's Neuromancer
books the graphics code the
visualization the interface is John
Carmack and John Romero the network code
is Mark Anderson the 3d graphics engine
that powers the whole thing is straight
out of the DNA of Silicon Graphics it is
virtual reality brought to life and it
seems hard now to imagine life without
it doesn't it you know I mean can you
imagine a world without blink imagine a
world without hyper Lisp
imagine a world without B boxes without
next books that's a bit of a stretch
isn't it so how much of that is true how
close did we come in 1981 IBM went
shopping for an operating system they
knocked on gary kildall door the founder
of digital research - by CPM to run on
the IBM personal computer and gary
kildall was out he had gone flying
because it was a nice day there is a
slightly less romantic version of this
story where he just didn't like them and
told them to piss off
but they gave him first call he for
whatever reason did not take it
they went knocked on the next name on
their list which was this enterprising
young man mr. William H Gates the third
of my crew - soft who in our universe by
the way are building a little hyper list
for debugging tools out of an office in
Seattle about ten fifteen people you
know nice little operation friendly
people it could have happened
you know IBM could probably one or two
meetings away Microsoft would never have
become the company they did and the IBM
PC would have taken over the world
running a digital research based
operating system Tim berners-lee the
world wide web let me let me ask you why
don't start with one historical question
if I could it again you know we live in
the world and part you created the
architecture for if you think back to
the start if you had it to do all over
again would you change anything what
would you have done differently it's a
good question and of course you can
never ask what would have happened if
you'd have done something differently
there was some I mean there's some some
simple things in fact when I designed
the URI URL that this thing which stops
HTTP colon slash slash - the slash slash
was to indicate that we are actually
starting at the top that we're not
starting down with the next slash but
the but a cool line in there is well it
turns out people never use the slash -
without the HTTP colon on it turns out
really if you think about you don't need
this knife slash I could have designed
it to not have the session boy now that
people know people all over the people
on the radio are calling it backslash
backslash means that everybody's people
haven't they use that finger so much
think of the amount of you know of print
now that would have been sage if we
wouldn't have sales if I just remove the
double slash but there you go yeah and
you can't it seems like a good idea at
the time could have been different HTML
you know it's based on sgml that's where
we got the angle brackets from sgml
wasn't the only markup language latex
has been around since what the early
1970s this is what latex markup syntax
uses lots of people at son knew later it
could so easily
HTML could have been based on something
else Microsoft had rich text format
going back to the late 1980s HTML could
have been based on rich text format the
idea of embedding Lisp as a programming
language via web was a real company Paul
Graham and his partners really were
building web servers in Lisp in the
mid-1990s they sold via web to Yahoo and
that's what you know made him a
millionaire he went on to found Y
Combinator with the revenue he made out
of that Lisp was embedded in all kinds
of things
AutoCAD came with an embedded Lisp
system Emacs came with an embedded Lisp
system it was the natural choice of
programming language there's even one
version of the story that says you know
when when Netscape approached Brendan
Eich they said we want you to come and
work for us because we want you to put
Lisp in the browser and what ended up
being JavaScript was a combination of
time pressure and marketing pressure and
if this doesn't look like C it's gonna
frighten everybody John Carmack and John
Romero really did port super super Mario
3 to the IBM PC and they sent a disc to
Nintendo but in our timeline Nintendo
didn't say that's fantastic come and
work for us and in tendo said that is
fantastic and if it ever sees the light
of day we are gonna sue you so hard you
won't be able to find the crater because
Nintendo had no interest at all in
people being able to pirate their games
that Nintendo cartridge the physical
Hardware was a fantastically effective
copy protection mechanism Marc
Andreessen and Jim Clarke really did get
wormers to the point of signing a deal
with Nintendo to go and build a gaming
network and if they had that's what they
would have done instead of starting
Netscape Netscape would never happen
Mark Anderson wouldn't have ended up
barefoot on the cover of Time magazine
standing in front of a pile of money you
know and that was these these two really
smart people going what do we want to
work on next that looks kind of fun that
looks kind of fun maybe we'll do that
one
now we'll do that one that's how easily
it could have happened cello was real
real web browser ran on Microsoft
Windows written by Thomas Bruce who was
the head librarian at Cornell Law School
it was a real thing B us was a real
operating system written by two former
Apple employees there were
real meetings between the the engineers
behind BIOS and Jill Emilio prior to
Apple managing to acquire next getting
Steve Jobs to come back he came out with
the the iMac the iPod the iPhone you
know Apple's resurgence from a company
who were nearly on the brink of death to
a trillion-dollar market cap is almost
entirely down to the things they did
after Steve Jobs came back into the fold
in the in the 1990s and Google being up
for sale they tried to sell to excite
for $800,000 Google they were
established they had the reputation they
had you know this formidable thing they
just did not have a business plan they
were trying to sell it to excite anyone
remember excite yeah anyone used excite
like in living memory they were an
internet portal they were search engine
they could have bought Google for 800
grand and they passed they said now we
don't think your company is going to
amount to anything
Google of course now is basically owns
the world and it's listening to every
word we say and indexing it all in case
it needs it all later and you know the
the lesson I mean that this talk is
designed to be thought-provoking and
interesting and kind of cover a little
bit history but I think the main if you
want to take a lesson away from this so
many of these systems that we use and we
rely on every day are not there because
somebody worked really really hard to
find the best solution or to make the
best decision or to find the best
possible team or circumstances to work
with they're there because people found
something that was just good enough and
they thought about what can we do with
it
what's gonna be next cuz you know we
have this thing in our industry analysis
paralysis where you get overwhelmed with
choice you don't know what to do next
literally you could do anything you have
a dozen different platforms to choose
from and you know almost all the web
development we do now is based on top of
a browser that might never have existed
if they'd gone to make a games network
instead running a programming language
that was bolted together in ten days by
somebody under marketing pressure from
Sun Microsystems even if you don't get
those decisions right
there isn't really a right and wrong all
there is is have we got enough to go on
and and make progress and as you see in
this talk we could have ended up making
a very very different kind of progress
maybe we still will but back here in the
real world
enjoy Chrome and Firefox and Safari and
Microsoft edge but that was the web that
never was thank you